une vidéo sans son diffusée à la
télévision russe pour sa première
apparition publique depuis la mutinerie
avortée du groupe Wagner le ministre de
la Défense apparaît en train d'inspecter
les troupes russes en Ukraine
l'air calme Sergei écoute un rapport
étudie des cartes géographiques ou fait
un tour d'hélicoptère pour inspecter les
positions russes une manière pour le
président Vladimir Poutine de montrer
qu'il maîtrise la situation deux jours
après la rébellion avortée du groupe
paramilitaire Wagner samedi le chef du
groupe avait promis de libérer le peuple
russe en visant notamment ses deux
ennemis jurés le ministre de la Défense
et le chef d'état-major qu'il critique
depuis des semaines on essaye de faire
en sorte que les criminels Sergueï of
qui ont détruit les centaines de
milliers de soldats russes ne puissent
pas sauver leur peau
critique féroce de la stratégie
militaire russe en Ukraine efghani privé
n'a finalement mis fin à la rébellion
qu'il avait lancé vendredi deux jours
plus tard Vladimir Poutine entend
montrer que tout est sous contrôle le
régime d'opération antiterroriste
instauré samedi à Moscou et dans sa
région a été levé ce lundi